tras más de ocho horas de debate el
parlamento de Perú finalmente rechazó la
propuesta de adelantar las elecciones
generales a octubre de este año para ser
aprobado el proyecto necesitaba 87 votos
a favor y apenas junto con la mitad han
votado a favor cuarenta y cinco
congresistas en contra sesenta y cinco
dos abstenciones señores congresistas al
no haber alcanzado el número de votos
previstos en el artículo dos cero seis
de la Constitución el proyecto de
reforma constitucional no ha sido
aprobado se presentó un pedido de
reconsideración del voto que podría
debatirse el lunes en una nueva sesión
Aunque es poco probable que cambiar
resultado la presidenta llena boluarte
había llamado El Congreso a adelantar
las elecciones para salir el país de la
crisis pero este sábado cientos de
manifestantes seguían protestando en las
calles de la capital lima para pedir de
boluarte el cierre del Congreso y la
convocatoria de una asamblea
Constituyente no vamos a
hacer la capital es que Dina Duarte de
una vez que renuncie queremos que
renuncie no queremos ni diálogo nada
queremos con esa asesina tantos hermanos
muertos llegó al poder hace siete
semanas cuando el expresidente Pedro
Castillo intentó disolver al parlamento
y fue acusado de organizar un auto golpe
de estado desde entonces no paran las
protestas y los bloqueos de carreteras
que ya han dejado cerca de 60 fallecidos